uh what do you think about the george
soros appointed district attorneys do
you think that they play a role in
allowing a lot of criminals to to be let
off for a lot of the violent crimes for
a lot of the some people say petty
crimes but but i i think there might be
a correlation with a lot of people being
sent off well while they're committing
hard crimes meanwhile political crime i
would argue is being prosecuted very
heavy-handedly especially if you believe
in the wrong kind of political ideology
yeah well let me i want to jump to a
story here actually because this is a
really really crazy tweet i saw from
mike cernovich yeah cervich says judge
amy jackson released a j6 defendant from
pretrial custody after he disavowed
trump in a letter and his lawyer
suggested a political conversion i've
never seen anything like this ever
so here's a guy who's been in jail now
for what is it going on nine months
and there's been horrifying conditions
there's a guy whose hand was broke and
they gave him medical treatment the
judge held the was it the warden and the
and the director of the department of
corrections i guess got held in contempt
and now you've they've seen the writing
on the wall
disavow the politics you previously
supported and they'll let you go call
this this re-education right this is the
state of of our current political and
law enforcement environment if that's
the case
i think we are
are we already beyond that that that red
line past the yeah yeah september 11th
in the patriot act was the red line when
they signed the patriot act they crossed
the red line
there's there's a lot of stuff that
happened throughout history though
there's a lot there's there that's true
i think that was a major turning point
but there were other things that people
you could take across on the gulf of
tonkin crossing they can arrest anyone
at any time with that then there was the
ndk
indefinitely for no reason
what that's insane
well there you go i guess they're doing
it well i i would just kind of go back
to the point what do you think about the
kind of prosecution of political crimes
while george soros's appointed ag's
usually let a lot of criminals off yeah
i mean you know i think i think the
progressive prosecutor movement you know
it's harder to track um what's going on
one of the reasons you're able to
criticize cop people able to criticize
customer effectively is because big city
police departments release a lot of
information uh da's offices are not
actually that transparent like you
they're some of these progressive
offices are getting a little more
transparent which is nice because you
can see where they're not prosecuting uh
larry krasner not pursuing gun crimes in
philadelphia for example um
it's hard to figure out what the impact
has been in the short run but i suspect
in the long run like petty crime will
flourish if you look at a city like san
francisco what has happened with
shoplifting there is clearly in part a
byproduct of the state's decision to say
that a theft under 950 dollars will no
longer be treated as felonious theft
it's partially a product of decisions by
da's like chesapeade to say
uh these offenses are not a serious
issue these minor offenses this goes
back to the point i was making earlier
it's like if behavior is perceived as
socially deviant in certain ways then
it's considered acceptable and not
deserving of punishment if behavior is
perceived as you know i don't have a
strong opinion about this particular
case i don't know all the details but i
think it is certainly true that people
can be prosecuted if not by the law and
certainly public opinion for
uh opinions which are not deemed
acceptable by the mainstream media by
public commentators uh in a way that
they are not for doing things like petty
shoplifting across uh running a
shoplifting room across san francisco i
think a lot of cops are also
disenfranchised i think there's a lot
more of the blue flu going around than
we even know about i think that's one of
the reasons but but also it's kind of
understandable because a lot of these
cops are like okay i booked this guy i
risked my life to put him in jail and
then he's just let out the next day what
the hell is going on here why should i
even risk my safety to do this again
when everyone also hates me so i think
there's an element of this that that
should be talked about and considering
when you talk about something like bail
reform um and you know they're they're
better you know i think i think there's
a stronger even the cash bail is not a
great idea that you you shouldn't be let
in or out of jail because of your
ability to pay as opposed to your risk
to society which is something you can do
but you look at a
new york state's original bail law which
rather than assessing risk uh just sort
of released people
create a strong presumption of release
for many classes of offenders and the
effect was you were seeing guys get
picked up and arrested 20 times and they
were out the very next day and it's like
what is the you're right what is the
point of running a criminal justice
system uh and my my colleague rafael
mangual at
the manhattan institute likes to say
criminals don't specialize the guy who
is getting picked up for
like uh jumping a turn style or public
decency he's the same guy who thinks
it's cool to jack a car and that's the
same there's there's a case in a
terrible case in san francisco guy stole
a guy was out on bail thanks chess
boudin stole the car shoot him in prison
shoot him in jail uh and ran over and
killed two pedestrians uh an old lady
and her and her daughter her her niece
um
it's it's it's a horrible case and you
know what happens is that criminals
don't specialize the guy the guy who
gets who gets stuck in jail for one
thing will it gets let out
he is often the guy who goes on to more
serious offense either
there are powerful elites that know
they're burning the country to the
ground and they like the fact that many
of these leftist and establishment
democrat types are too stupid to know
what's going on or
they're all really stupid and just
marching in lockstep because they're not
smart enough to realize they're burning
the place to the ground you look at the
policies in the cities with these soros
da's and they're like i'm gonna release
this violent offender and then he kills
somebody and it's like well who could
have seen that coming i kind of agree
with you charles that there are like two
types of people one that respects the
law and one that doesn't respect the law
but then i see people like julian
assange and edward snowden who they made
specific crimes that you gotta wonder is
that law just that they'd violated like
was hitler's restoration of the
professional civil service of april 7
1933 which excluded jews from civil
service was that a just law
i mean no no it wasn't i like i like
being the civil servant the criminals
that violated that law weren't the kind
of criminals that would mug someone yes
sure and and and even even
uh not nazi germany can create we can
create unjust laws we live in just laws
now i think so uh but like part of the
principle of liberty and republic is
that we don't get to flaunt laws that we
don't like right like like we live under
we we have some agreement um i think i
think it is i think it is like it's not
necessarily that everybody's malicious
not even necessarily that i've been
stupid it's like i think about the mayor
of seattle jenny durkin durkheim i
forget her last name um who looked at
the at the chas chop zone and was like
this is the summer of love
like these people they went to our house
you know the people who are getting shot
and murdered in europe and chicago and
baltimore are not the people who are
running the city uh 90 plus percent of
homicide victims in new york city every
year are black or hispanic they're not
the people who are running you know eric
adams is a black dude he lives in new
jersey but he is a black dude um but
generally he he's not coming from the
context of the people who are getting
shot so i think a lot of it comes down
to sort of abstraction into political
ideology it's like i believe that these
people are at the center of systems of
oppression so i just need to sort of
liberate them from this it's like nah i
don't think it's that genuine i don't
think it's that loving and caring these
people don't live with them they're not
in the same communities and i agree with
that particular point but to think that
a lot of these people making these
policies are not seeing the effects of
them i think
is not a realistic point i think they
know exactly what they're doing i think
it's leading to a system that they want
a situation that they want that has
people fighting each other arguing with
each other it has people unhappy has
people unhealthy has people being
victims of crime more than ever and i
think that benefits a system that
thrives off of that and and i think i
would i would argue that rather than i
know what's right i'm going to help
these people
they pretend to say that but at the end
of the day they know that they're not
doing that
i i don't like that uh
that rep small group of representatives
are in charge of making the laws anymore
it doesn't seem right with
350 million of us that have access to
the internet and doing this together
that we've given it up the power to like
600 people it doesn't make any sense
because you see these bastardized laws
that they're creating and enforcing and
like the ndaa
they can just d grab someone out of
their house and stick them in guantanamo
for as long as they want that's that's
not when they were when they took a what
are they like a red what was it a red
writer a little wagon with 5 000 pages
for the omni mus bill and they're like
carding it into the congress and they're
like nobody read it nobody's gonna read
it let's make it a law
that's a that's a functional system
right there huh
no no it's not
thank you thank you
good point idiot i appreciate that but i
think there's a bigger conversation to
be had here because
when we look at the statistics
especially within the last few months
the people are getting screwed over here
people are getting hurt more than ever
people are being victims of crime more
than ever people are becoming more
unhealthy more unhappy uh
you know they're getting robbed
economically every step of the way here
and and a lot of this comes from a lot
of these politicians saying i'm going to
help you they're not helping you they
know they're not helping you because
look who's benefiting off of this a lot
of multinational corporate elites a lot
of billionaires who are making raking in
record profits while everyone else is
having a harder time making it by to be
fair i mean
you can just follow nancy pelosi and buy
what she buy the stocks that she buys
right and and and and come on when all
this went down it should have been
obvious to everybody that you could just
buy the stock for pfizer johnson johnson
moderna amazon is walmart's private
though is walmart's not publicly traded
i think it's private you could have
about amazon stock that went through the
roof so of course it was benefiting the
billionaires
but it was also benefiting the
millionaires
see so if you were a millionaire you
were doing all right oh you guys are
talking about working-class people oh
yeah the working-class people were
screwed completely
you know i think i think sort of my my
response to that point is so like this
is not the worst violent crime has been
in the united states right there there's
a
uh for viewers under the age of 30 who
do not remember i i'm under the age of
30 but like for viewers who do not
remember the 80s and 90s um
homicide rates were substantially higher
violent crime rates uh you couldn't walk
through times square in new york city
because it was like a den of
prostitution iniquity well hold on do
you know why homicide rates were
substantially higher before 2007. why
cell phones
all right lack of cell phones
so
one thing that needs to be considered
that um when it comes to tracking the
homicide rate
is that once cell phones became
ubiquitous
violent crime that resulted in death
became violent crime that didn't result
in death because people could call 9-1-1
immediately whereas before this
they would rush to find a phone and so
what ends up happening is there's an
illusion that there's a major drop-off
in violent crime when there isn't
there's it's the same there's a similar
level of crime it is going down yeah so
so the violent crime rate declined
substantially by 1994 the homicide rate
falls from about 1989 um and actually
there's a leveling off around the great
recession in the in the violent crime
rate of the night in the house
that actually meant that that violent
crime was skyrocketing right or so i'll
put it this way
homicides changed because of cell phones
into attempted murders and so you had
less people dying that substantially
changed the nature of how crimes were
being reported so when you look at the
great recession it's like oh it's flat
actually people are surviving the
violent attacks i mean you would you
would you would expect an increase in
the aggregate in the aggravated soldier
violent crime rate then which doesn't
happen i mean i i i believed in
improvements in trauma medicine and uh
so so there's a great um you look at uh
what's his name
uh stephen pinker that it could be that
people weren't reporting the crimes yeah
there's a corpse on the ground it gets
reported yeah so so i mean
the homicide is sort of the historically
most reliable indicator right because of
course on the ground um but like we can
plausibly compare the 1990s to the early
2000s we say that violent crime is
substantially lower um you can you can
quibble about like what the what the
direction of that is with the magnitude
of the change but it's like it's
definitely down the point that i wanted
to make is that like violent crime rose
in the 60s and 70s uh i think largely
for ideological reasons there
all of the same ideas were in the water
that we should convert the the the
criminal system would be primarily
rehabilitative that cops were violent
and dangerous and racist and that they
needed to be like frankly they were more
violent and dangerous and racist than
they are now like cops were way worse 50
years ago than they are today 60 years
ago than they are today um
that uh that what we really needed was
like a more therapeutic state that like
looked after everybody and these ideas
like had enormous currency in the 60s
and 70s uh and there was a there was a
retraction of criminal justice capacity
there was a retraction of uh policing
and incarcerate incarceral capacity and
the result was predictable like these
ideas go in and out of fashion they come
in and out of style and i think that
they're coming back now thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time